you do it no yeah I can't complain you
you've been nervous
how you feeling it's been pretty good
yeah it's uh how you think the preseason
went uh this one pretty good you know
yeah well look man you know the odds are
stacked against you from the from the
jump man you did a lot of good things
this camping yes we appreciate your hard
work
just want to let you know man you're in
New York chest
I feel like he's scaring me
welcome to the team brother
20 minute drive
you're gonna you're gonna do a lot of
good things for us this year you got you
got something to you the way you
approach the game with your intent your
mindset and all that stuff like there's
no doubt in our mind that you're going
to maximize who you are yes yeah uh
you're definitely one of us
foreign